et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec benjamin amar porte parole
cgt 94
frédéric jeanjean secrétaire générale de
l'umih 13 bonsoir à tous les deux merci
d'être avec nous alors pas de re
confinement pour l'instant pas d'euro
confinement strict parce que tout dépend
de la définition qu'on en a reconquis de
man mais le gouvernement maintient la
pression vu les chiffres gabriel atta le
porte parole du gouvernement a déclaré à
nadège venez de le dire abderrazak qu'il
existait bien un chemin pour éviter leur
confinement qu'il n'était pas là ce
chemin mais il existait nous aurions
tort de ne pas tout mettre en oeuvre
pour y parvenir est ce que ce chemin
justement emprunté par le gouvernement
frédéric jeanjean c'est à dire le
maintien du couvre-feu s'avoue satisfait
globalement où violences et un semi
confinement qui nous casse les pieds et
qui nous empêchent de travailler on va
être très clair qui est une épidémie on
en est tous conscients on est tous
d'accord sur les problèmes que rencontre
l'ensemble de la planète à l'heure
actuelle nous ce que nous préconisons
aujourd'hui c'est la réouverture de nos
établissements par les terrasses parce
que toutes les études nous ont dit que
en plein air il ya moins de
contamination possible avec un respect
d'un protocole sanitaires très strictes
je vous rappelle que les protocoles
sanitaires mis en place dans la
restauration
nous avons participé nous avons demandé
à les mettre en place
nous allons même initié avec le cahier
de rappelle que le gouvernement refusait
dans un premier temps pour finalement il
venir
donc il s'agit d'être responsable mais
on se retrouve aussi avec des personnes
qui sont en grande détresse et pas
qu'économique
comme jeudi les restaurateurs c'est les
gens qui travaillent 12 à 15 heures par
jour et du jour au lendemain on nous
renvoie à la maison sans perspectives
alors on s'est dit à la possibilité de
rouvrir en travaillant sur les terrasses
parce qu'il ya une en deux parties la
france où à l'heure actuelle on peut
commencer à travailler puis on va y
travailler de plus en plus et on se dit
que c'est une piste à étudier à regarder
parce que ça évite les espaces clos
les salles de restaurant et c'est sur
quoi nous nous sommes en train de
travailler en ce moment en ce moment
mais d'ici là vous aurez le temps
certainement de voir les beaux jours
arrivent et alors pendant que ces
restaurateurs un voleur rouvrir certains
syndicats demandent à refermer les
écoles parce que les variants on suscite
évidemment de grosses préoccupations
dans les établissements scolaires
benjamin a marre vous voudriez
clairement gros confiné ou pas quelle
est votre position sur le sujet
j'écoutais ce que vous disiez les propos
de gabriella talent si décidément un
sacré randonneurs parce qu' il aime
beaucoup cette expression sûr nous avons
un showman z même coup au moment de la
vaccination
nous avons un chemin sur la vaccination
le problème c'est que ce chemin nous
donnent le tournis mais ils donnent le
tournis en fait à l'ensemble des
français
la question que vous posiez c'est que
veulent finalement les français mais en
réalité je pense que les français ils
veulent un peu de cohérence
tout simplement moi j'ai une question
qui est que tu as équipe qui
m'interpelle beaucoup j'étais moi
dimanche rue de rivoli je me promenais
et les magasins et les magasins étaient
ouverts les magasins de vêtements gtrra
été ouvert un magasin de chaussures
étaient ouverts et vais beaucoup de
monde
il y avait beaucoup de monde et moi je
me demandais puisque les grands musées
nationaux ils sont à deux pas il ya le
loup et le muguet lequel il ya musée
d'orsay et puis et ben je sais pas je me
disais mais qu'est ce qui fait que on
est en sécurité lorsqu on est dans le
magasin avec un masque et qu'on achète
une un jean et on n'est pas en sécurité
quand on va au musée avec le même masque
et et on regarde effectivement à un
tableau de un tableau de rembrandt ou ou
un tableau de 2,2 d'andrea mantegna je
vois pas
il n'y a pas de cohérence en réalité et
je pense que c'est ça dans ce que vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure ça me faisait
penser moi à la à propos par exemple de
ce que vous évoquez sur sur le fait que
désormais l'épidémie alors étaient
présents
dès octobre ou novembre bah écoutez et
jusqu'à présent on ne vous avait dit au
départ c'est en janvier puis c'est en
décembre
ça me fait penser à la phrase de pascal
vérité au delà des pyrénées m'enfonçant
de ça et bien en fonction des mois et
des semaines les choses varie bakr en
osant syndicats enseignants dont vous
parliez nous on est cohérent ce que l'on
demande c'est alors on n'est pas obsédé
sur la question du confinement mais on
veut que justement il ya une une
question de sécurité sanitaire qui
soient prises en compte
les variants arrivent ils inquiètent
beaucoup sur leur virulence hurleurs
contagion est là sachant ce que nous dit
monsieur bancaire cest tout va très bien
ouvrir les fenêtres
c'est passionnant le protocole a été
quand même renforcé en tous les parents
le sac mais tant qu'anti invariants sud
africain dans une classe on ferme toute
la classe ans et c'est quand même devenu
la règle à peu près dans toutes les
écoles françaises on le dit peut-être
pas mais c'est quand même le cas contre
on a des enfants à l'école on le sait
alors écoutez quand on a des enfants à
l'école très bien moi je suis
enseignante stéphanie je suis enseignant
et je peux vous dire faites donc un
sondage auprès des collègues
quels sentiments ils ont quel réalité à
changer pour de bon
moi dans mon lycée dans mon
établissement scolaire il ya rien qui a
changé et vous voulez je vous dise
pourquoi parce que la détection des cas
contacté des cas positifs
je peux même pas vous dire qu'il ya des
trous dans la raquette c'est le tamis de
la raquette qui manquent
voilà j'ai râlé demandé aux collègues et
aux familles
comment ça se passe réellement le riz la
rigueur le sérieux sur la détection des
cas contacts on nous avait dit qu'il
allait avoir des tests de dépistage
massif
on les attend comment entrer à la marée
alors attendez attendez deux minutes
alors à la rentrée très bien donc la
question qui se pose c'est qu'on nous
avait dit que ça allait vous vous
souvenez ça allait reposer sur les
médecins scolaires
je vais vous dire un truc moi les
médecins scolaires en 20 ans de carrière
j'en ai vu autant que des licornes
voilà donc on est sur des études
annoncent la réalité de la situation
sanitaire en france depuis le mois de
septembre
elle est en permanence minimisée par le
ministère et ceux qui ce qui ferait
qu'on serait sécurisé quelque part ce
serait cette question de comment on
détecte les cas contactez les cas
positifs mais ça honnêtement c'est pas
du tout rigoureux alors vous ce qu'on
dit depuis le début c'est bon sens
situation exceptionnelle moyen
exceptionnel c'est pas forcément le
continent mais c'est réquisition de
bâtiments recrutement de 2 comment dire
de personnel c'est une situation
d'urgence on fait exactement avec les
mêmes moyens que d'habitude et on
explique que tout va très bien mais
franchement qui on veut convaincre en
tout cas talent par les directives mans
oui on va donner aux gens tout de même
la sonnette d'alarmé
ce sont les médecins parfois qu'il
attire plus que les le gouvernement qui
entend temporiser un scientifique
science met un gilles pialoux un adage
abderrazak le site est également chef du
service des maladies infectieuses à
l'hôpital tenon à paris qui dit en gros
on a une poussée incroyable de se marier
en anglais 39% des nouvelles
contaminations en ile-de-france
situation alarmante sur le strict point
de vue sanitaire je ne vois pas comment
on peut échapper un confinement nous dit
il certaines certains dénoncent leur
haine des médecins trop alarmiste dans
le débat public c'est votre cas frédéric
jeanjean ce parce que en attendant les
restaurations et restaurateurs pardon et
les hôtels ne sont pas ouverts alors
qu'on espagne 1 on l'a pas évoqué tout à
l'heure mais en espagne en rouvrant les
restaurants on va être clair moi
j'entends ce que disent les médecins
j'aurais tendance à leur faire confiance
je me méfie par contre des analyses
statistiques est parce que dans une
statistique on lui fait dire ce que l'on
veut dans une étude faite par l'institut
pasteur qui ont fait état d'études et de
sondages on dit ce qu'on me donc là
dessus dans le jeu reste assez
circonspect mais je fais confiance aux
médecins
je fais confiance aux scientifiques le
président de la république lors j'ai
confiance
il aura même laissé les clefs du
gouvernement pendant des mois aux gens
ce qu'est ce qui est étonnant c'est quoi
notre j'avais un médecin en espagne qui
nous disait ici même sur ce plateau
devant mon étonnement à la réouverture
des restaurants que là-bas y avait des
études qui tendrait à prouver que et ben
le nombre de contaminations dans les
restaurants espagnols n'étaient pas si
si grande aux comptes
demande évidemment dans sur quelles
études on se base est là qu elle devrait
surtout mais c'est ce que je vous disais
l'étude qui nous a été présentée comme
une étude de l'institut pasteur était un
sondage est peut-être que les gens ont
répondu ce que on attendait qu'il
réponde aussi parce qu'une véritable
étude il n'y en a pas il ya eu ce
protocole de chicago des états unis mais
on n'a aucune étude sérieuse
à l'heure actuelle on nous a balancé un
enfumage avec l'histoire institut
pasteur pendant l'hiver mais qui n'est
rien du tout nous nous préconisons qu'on
n'ouvre les terrasses on voit les gens
manger sont regroupés dans les bureaux
le midi son angers côte à côte sur des
bornes ça se mettre sur les trottoirs
j'ai même vu des gens qui avaient pris
un carton pizza manger sur une poubelle
et on nous dit qu'ils font ça parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'endroit pour s'appuyer
parce que c'est en cas de crise
sanitaire alors si on met des tables si
on est des chaises qui peut y manger un
plat chaud ça me dire comment faire la
fiesta la bamboche on dit part d'un
gouvernement
eh bien écoutez il s'assoit ils peuvent
manger simplement ça permet d'avoir un
temps pour manger pour ceux qui sont en
déplacement professionnel
ça permet de pouvoir travailler un
moment ce qui manque c'est pas forcément
que de la cohérence de ce que disait
monsieur tout à l'heure c'est aussi
beaucoup de bon sens ce qui se passe
dans la vraie vie ce qui se passe avec
les français au quotidien ce que vous
voyez dans votre établissement comme
vous enseigner ce que nous voyons dans
la rue sur nos terrasses et au quotidien
et dans tous les commerces ont été pour
connaître ce concert on est menacé des
français clairement on n'est pas assez
sur le terrain il faudrait peut-être
donner le pouvoir aux élus dans les
régions sur le terrain c'est ce qui
manque clairement aujourd'hui en france
frédéric jeanjean
mais c'est qu'il faudrait d'abord les
écouter les élus sur le terrain
quand vous voyez les fonctionnements les
ars qui arrivent et qui ceux qui se
comportent comme les préfets maintenant
il devrait plutôt travailler localement
on est une étude par département par
région qu'on ait une approche qui soient
locales et qui serait peut être plus
efficace parce que si les comportements
d'après ce qu'on a bien compris qui font
qu'on se transmet le virus
donc c'est à partir de ces études là
qu'on arriverait à quelque chose de
cohérent
à proposer des solutions région avant de
faire ce débat s'il voulait pardonnez
moi messieurs vous interroger sur un
autre sujet qui fait débat en ce moment
ça concerne la vaccination ils passent
par vaccinale on va regarder tout
d'abord ces chiffres de seat co by
traqueur avant d'en discuter regarder
près de deux millions de personnes à peu
près ont reçu une première dose à peine
300 milles ont reçu la deuxième dose co
by traqueur qui en tire cette analyse
cela fait des semaines que nous dit
qu'on nous dit que le vaccin c'est la
clé un nouveau donc débat qui prend de
l'ampleur le passeport vaccinale pour
retrouver notre liberté vous êtes pour
ou contre n'a jamais à ma vous qui avez
eu copie d'un mais oui tout à fait
michael cohen et qui sait que cette
maladie est une infamie canton compte on
l'a sous sa forme nos graves
c'est une véritable peste mais moi je
suis un fervent partisan de la
vaccination mais en l'occurrence moi je
ne comprends pas c'est pour les huit
lancés par certains ce serait déjà bien
qu'on arrive à protat à vacciner ceux
qui le veulent et où ce serait déjà bien
qu'on arrive à faire ça on est une
logistique correct voilà parce que on
est dans le flou le plus complet alors
l'âge j'entendais qu'il y avait des
doutes sur le vaccin astrazeneca savez
quoi que j'ai déjà une campagne de
vaccination correct qu'on arrive à
vacciner ceux qui le souhaitent dans des
rythmes adéquate et ensuite on évoquera
d'autres débats mais si vous voulez y a
rien qui va
c'est en fait sur le vaccin mais comme
sur le reste il n'y a rien qui tient
c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté sur la
notion de cohérence
on vient d'apprendre que il fallait que
les que les masques comment dire de
tissus était inadéquat nous dans
l'éducation à la rentrée on nous en a
distribué fièrement donc moi j'aimerais
qu'on avant d'avoir ce genre de grands
débats et qui vole haut niveau des
éperviers des aigles que déjà on arrive
à avoir une gestion un tant soit peu
carré des problèmes qui se posent au
moment t voyez vous donc il est là le
problème
moi l'eau en l'occurrence je me suis
renseigné un petit peu pour savoir en
fonction de ma situation conteste que je
pourrais être vaccinés ce ne sera pas ce
sera pas avant la fin mars début avril
de quoi on parle avant polluer le débat
et de parler de ce genre de choses qui
eux mêmes bien évidemment un passeport
national
bien sûr que ça ça va susciter
légitimement plein de débat autour de la
liberté etc
mais au lieu de polluer le débat qu'on
arrive juste à vacciner correctement
ceux qui le souhaitent
visiblement il ya des millions de
personnes oui encore benjamin mars avril
nous est optimiste je croisais une dame
tout à l'heure dans la rue de 85 ans qui
se lamentaient qu'elle était elle avait
son premier rendez vous le 2 mai 1 voilà
et c'était cela ressemblait à un gros
problème frédéric jeanjean côté
vaccination vous même constat que
benjamin marronnage un petit peu dans
l'incohérence permanente
non c'est pas de l'incohérence c'est un
système car cayenne les technocrates ont
pris le pouvoir
vous savez moi j'ai ma belle famille qui
est dans l'ariège j'ai mes beaux parents
qui ont 86 et 77 ans ils sont
prioritaires pour être vaccinés mais ya
pas de vaccin dans l'ariège
donc pour l'instant c'est pas possible
on va voir quand ça va être envisageable
moi je vois je vois ces exemples un peu
partout c'est bien beau de parler du
passeport vaccinale encore faudrait-il
que les vaccins encore faut-il qu'ils
soient effectivement mis en place après
on demande ce serait bien aussi de
vérifier aux frontières on vient à peine
de s'y mettre pour les gens qui arrivent
j'ai un confrère l'inquiéter à dakar au
mois d'octobre
il est arrivé il m'a dit que le jeu
arrive à dakar je suis sorti de l'avion
immédiatement lui a fait le test 24
heures à l'hôtel il a fallu attendre et
vérifié il est revenu à marseille
provence à marignane
il arrivait de dakar il est sorti de
l'avion il est allé chercher sa valise
et après son taxi les rentrer chez lui
et personne n'a rien demandé
et maintenant on nous dit fonds passport
vaccinale mais un moment il va falloir
se mettre à réfléchir et à travailler
avec cohérence avec bon sens
il va falloir que les choses soient
faites non plus rapport aux sondages
parce que c'est par rapport aux sondages
comme ça on fixe la stratégie maintenant
parce que vous avez 40 % des français
qu'ils ont pas être confinée et 60
concerts qui sont pas d'accord et c'est
pour ça que l'on sent l'on change de
discours au niveau du gouvernement
et bien c'est insupportable c'est pas
les statistiques ni les sondages qui
vont arriver et qui vont dicter notre
quotidien merci à tous les deux
benjamins ma fabrique
jeanjean d'avoir porté votre voix et
peut-être que le gouvernement viendra
vous consultez sait-on jamais merci à
tous les deux seront bienvenus